AA you go from Christian conservative
family to only fan star and sex worker
how does that happen so I worked at a
factory for a year uh and I was like wow
this really
sucks it's better than like a life spent
working at the factory that was really
awful you think sex work is less bad
than working in a factory I mean depends
on the person but for me and a lot of
girls that I know who are in sex work it
was very Absol absolutely how do you be
seductive if I lower my voice and talk
slower and I don't use big words and I
smile make eye contact yeah yeah I'm
glad to I'm glad that we're that
predictable every single one of us you
must enjoy escorting y clearly right
which I was surprised to find
yeah Aya you go from Christian
conservative family to only fan star and
sex worker how does that happen uh a
long series of baby steps okay tell us
well like when you're raising a
Christian conservative home they kind of
don't prepare you for the real world at
least not the way that mine worked so
like homeschooled expected to be a
housewife kind of deal um so I got in
the real world and my realistically my
options um were not great so I worked at
a factory for a year uh and I was like
wow this really sucks um I don't have an
education and I'm really like culturally
isolated from the world uh like it was
really hard to like get along and
understand what was going on cuz you
know we weren't allowed to watch a lot
of normal media um and so I had a friend
who suggested trying camming cuz it was
he did camming and then I was like
really poor sipping on a friend's couch
I was like you know what I'll give it a
shot and made a lot of money the first
night uh and then one thing led to
another and I just like like oh this is
the the way to like uh have many in
agency um when there was no other option
for me well I'm guessing by this point
you would have had some kind of
ideological shift as well because not
many Christian conservatives would be
like I'm working in a factory sucks
let's try camming it's quite a
transition in terms of culture and all
of that right yeah very much I lost my
faith maybe like a year or so after I
left home um which was like a pretty
rapid shift I think like the exposure to
being in a non-Christian world really
helped me be able to think that maybe
Christianity was false like I think it's
very difficult to consider that
everything that you believe is wrong
when every part of your culture is in
mesh with this like every you don't know
anyone who disagrees like I didn't know
any non-christians in my personal life
uh so it's just like your brain just to
some degree can't literally cannot
consider this as an option um or at
least was quite hard it was quite hard
for me and so I think after I finally
left home and I was like briefly
attempted to do college um I was
surrounded by people who weren't
Christian and they were living life and
being happy and fine and it was okay
somehow and then this somehow let
allowed some part of my subconscious to
be like maybe this is all false is there
any part of so because you talk about
leaving Christianity is there any part
of religion that you miss because
there's a lot of people who say you know
what it gives me a lot of structure it
gives me purpose it gives me direction
yeah absolutely it's like something
that's a lot of people have tried to
replicate outside of religion it's
really hard to do for a lot of reasons
but yet there's like the there intense
Community you just have like a pre build
community that trusts each other uh like
a lot of help like for example my family
moved from California to Idaho when I
was quite young and they just had like a
church in Idaho like send out all of
their people to help us unload move in
and out of like various apartments for
free for no reason it was just like
because you're part of the community you
get you're part of the ingroup you get
this kind of help and that's super cool
yeah I mean it is and particularly
nowadays where people are struggling for
Community I mean did you find that
diffult the the loss of a community the
loss of structure a bit I found
community in other cam girls at the time
so that helped a lot and then I found
rationalists which uh in a lot of ways
actually operate kind of similar to
churches so the fly finds you very
attractive and they can't stay away it's
into you it's into you it's one of your
fans um so um you you start
camming uh and what's that like great it
was scary the first night but after that
it kind of got fine and I was pretty
awkward like a lot of uh instruction
about how to be flirty and seductive as
a woman like the general uh like you
watch movies like teen movies about how
you flirt and what kind of things mean
what I didn't really have any of that
like to the degree where I remember my
first time at a bar somebody walked up
to me and offered me like can I buy you
a drink and I was like sure and they
bought me a drink and I just took it I
walked
away I didn't understand that that was
like a cultural indication of interest
to me it was literally I want to give
you money to for alcohol and I'm like
that is a nice stranger so it's like
this level of not understanding you're
very literal a
very like someone comes up to you gives
you a drink you're like thank you and
just walk away that guy must have been
devastated yeah I know I feel really bad
looking in hindsight he's like oh he
probably thinks women are but no
I'm just um either Autistic or
homeschooled or
both unclear um but yeah so I I really
did not have a lot of the organic
understanding of what it's like to be a
seductive woman like how you're supposed
to Signal this um and so a lot of my
early years camming was um very goofy uh
I just was very funny I was a mime a sex
mime um and I would use wacky stuff all
the time before eventually figuring out
that that's not the best way to make
money so how it's interesting it sounds
to me like you've had to almost kind of
mechanically work out how to do certain
things that you didn't get get from your
upbringing or whatever and one of them
is being seductive how do you be
seductive well it's a multi-step process
so what I'm doing right now this is not
seductive if I were like trying to like
eek you for all the money you had
there's no way that this would work um
but if I like if I like adjust my
posture slightly um and if I lower my
voice and talk slower and I don't use
big words and I smile
make eye
contact and really drop like my sphere
of energy into my lower stomach
um it does a lot better yeah yeah I'm
glad to I'm glad that we're that
predictable every single one of us that
that that makes sense logically
logically that makes sense but it took
me so long to figure that out like when
I was camming I had a a paper with like
rules for myself so it's caming it's
very rapid feedback you get like live
people coming in you see the numbers of
your room rise and fall depending on
what you're doing you see your money per
hour averaged over the last 60 days is
shown as a score this is my free cams so
you get like very rapid instruction
about the kinds of behaviors you're
doing that work or not um so I I had a
paper behind my webcam which is the
rules I eventually figured out which was
smile always uh keep eye contact with
the camera talk really slowly way slower
than you think you need to and use
Simple language just and that when I did
that my money increased quite a lot why
do you think you have to use Simple
language I it's like I I think it's
there's like a couple theories some of
them flattering and some of them not
like one of them is like if you're very
horny you're probably not thinking in
like higher brained language you're
probably just which is kind of true
right which is legitimate so if you if
you want to give like a really
intentional signal that you are aroused
you know you probably shouldn't be using
multi cabic language or whatever yeah uh
but another one is that like you don't
want to appear too intimidating like you
want to be ible this is like one of the
biggest rules for seduction is you want
to be as accessible as possible and as
reactive as possible and if you're using
like big language maybe it's is subtly
signaling to the men that like oh I'm
going to have to try harder to have an
impact on her in the way that I want and
Aya was this only fans or was this a
platform before only fans when you
started this is my free cams which is
actually owned by the person who bought
only fans before I okay this was what
what year was this uh this is this was
when I was like 21 or 20 years old to 25
or 26 cool so that was how long ago now
just and I'm 31 okay all right so
because I'm just trying to work out at
what point of the internet because now
apparently only fans is super
competitive Y super competitive so when
you started that was was it like a Gold
Rush era for camming uh no camming had
been around like maybe 5 10 years
earlier before I started um it it was it
was sort of the Golden Era but it wasn't
like a spike in the way that we see this
happened to only fans with only fans
that like came in and it changed the
world and with like my free cams and
related cam sites it was like a slow
climb over you know the early 2000s yeah
um you say change the world how did only
fans change the world it's just
radically changed the internet like I
I'm a big internet person I feel like
internet is my culture I grew up on the
internet I love the internet and the
introduction of only fans like modified
rules across the internet in order to
handle only fans like uh one of the
things that I'm not sure if only fans
did intentionally but might be genius is
that they don't have internal Discovery
um which is like for example what my
free cams had in every other public sex
site as far as I can tell had internal
Discovery that's like the value that
it's giving but the only fans if you
internal Discovery is when you can be
found on the platform by accident or by
being recommended is that what in Yeah
by like recomendation right you watch a
video you get a bunch of suggestions
that's what you're talking about right
yeah so if you put a video on YouTube
you expect YouTube to provide the
viewers to your video you don't have to
go out and like post on Twitter and be
like hey guys come see my video yes um
so with only fans they have no internal
discovery which means that if I'm a girl
and only fans and I want subscribers
what do I have to do I have to go out to
other websites and post my link and try
and convince people to come subscribe to
me um and this is just every user on
only fans that makes any money has to do
this which means that we saw like a
rapid influx of any place on the
internet that allowed not safe for work
posting just became completely dominated
by only and they had to change the rules
to handle that and why wouldn't you use
your own website to do that where do you
get the traffic for that website but you
are having to bring the traffic to only
fans yes so you Reddit for example is a
great thing or Tik Tok or Instagram
those things will promote your video to
other people those have internal
Discovery so you post something that
like is a sexy video to one of these
platforms and then people see it and
then you have a funnel and then you they
go find your only fans I know but what
I'm saying is why would you not just use
your own website instead of only fans oh
it's well it's very hard I so I did look
into this so I misunderstood what you
were saying um because like only fans
takes 20% and you're like maybe I right
but uh payment processors are terrible
if you want to use payment processors to
accept funds for what you're building um
and you're selling not safe for work
stuff the fees are massive and I think
it's my understanding that only fans
because they're doing such huge volume
managed to negotiate some sort of like
lower fees for those payment processors
but if you're doing it as an individual
you have no bargaining power um and I
looked into it and it was just you can't
I wouldn't be able to I would be losing
20% easily and just for the cost of
setting up the website it's just not
worth it and I mean only fans is one of
those things that became super
successful over the pandemic like I mean
do you know how much is turnover now are
only fans how much money are they making
they must be making I don't know massive
still because it just seems that it just
hit the Ze guys whereas before I'd never
even been aware of it yeah it was around
for years beforehand it started in 200
17 I think I think that's what I joined
I I remember joining only fans and
nobody was on it nobody had heard of it
and I like posted some things and made
like 40 bucks and then never signed on
again um so it's really weird and why do
you think I mean uh not to State the
obvious too much but there's a lot of
porn on the Internet yeah I don't know
if you noticed um why do you think the
camming thing is taken off in the way
that it has as opposed to watching you
know ER video produced by a porn Studio
whatever I mean I think there's a subset
of men for which it's very interesting
like lots of guys like don't care about
the thing where you pay for interaction
but we have examples like strip clubs
throughout history are really nice you
go and the girl you know makes you feel
special for a little while I think
that's a big part of why only fans and
camming are successful it's because like
despite the stereotypes for a lot of men
uh like sex is not completely separable
from uh romantic interaction like it's
very much about validation like guys
like when I was an escort um about 80% I
would say roughly of men really wanted
to make sure I had a good time uh even
though they didn't have to they were
paying me a ridiculous amount of money
for me to do whatever they wanted and
they spent that time trying to please me
and so I think like what guys are really
want is like for a woman to sort of like
gaze upon Him sexually and be like yes
you are valuable I am sexually aroused
by you uh I affirm you as a sexual being
and that's not something that porn can
do um who's the type of person that uses
only fans is it all male is it male and
female does it have like a component
where a couple will watch a cam girl
together occasionally but it's quite low
I haven't actually like tracked stats
for this but off top my head it's a 99%
male yeah every once in a while I get
like a couple being like hey we watched
you together and then even rarer than
that I get like a lady who's like I'm
gay I'm really into you but it's almost
entirely men it's almost entirely men I
mean look that that does make a that
does make a lot of sense and and when
did you know that you were on to
something that you could you could make
this really work for you for only fans
yeah pretty fast the thing is like I I
just happened to already be in a
position for only fans to work for me
I've been doing sex work for a long time
um but I'm not very uh I'm not like a
top 10 at Char charisma skill in person
so if I'm doing a thing where I have to
seduce a lot of men by acting like this
like it's it's quite I have to figure it
out top down a lot of girls were able to
emanate this bottom up but only fans the
strength is not in being charismatic
strength is and knowing how to Market
how to uh like how to Market to men how
to do funnels how to like track
conversion like most of my job with only
fans was not posting only fans it was
like 80% sitting behind spreadsheets um
when I was doing it all time doesn't
sound that sexy when you when you say it
like that it's not um and I'm curious I
mean obviously the the one thing we
haven't talked about and this isn't
going to be news to you but um doing sex
work online exposes you to a lot of
people and with that come certain risks
so here you are you have a factory job
you tried this caming for for a night
you make more money than you make at the
factory um did you at that point think
well like this is not this has got some
serious trade-offs let's put it like
that I mean in contrast to the factory
like I I mean I was vaguely aware of
them but like my current life was so bad
I was willing to take them and in
hindsight it's still worth it but for a
long time it wasn't that bad because I
wasn't super well known mm um and it's
been getting worse recently but it it
does there are downsides like I'm not
saying that like every girl should just
go try sex work if you're desperate is
probably better for you because like
even with the downsides it's better than
like a life spent working at the factory
that was really awful um but you think
sex work is less bad than working in a
factory I mean depends on the person
people have different constitutions and
tolerance for things like I'm not
universally recommending it but for me
and a lot of girls that I know who are
in sex work it was very absolutely
they're like I can't believe that people
are so this happens all the time I'm
like oh I'm in sex work and people are
like oh are you okay like are you
worried about the downsides you know and
I'm like nobody ever said that to me
when I worked at the factory which was
way worse for my mental health I was
like drinking to cope and that's like a
classic sign of like oh this is really
hard for you but I never had a drink to
cope with being a sex worker but I think
the thing that people think when they
see sex works one of the downsides
should we say is a reputational damage
Al particularly for a woman you know if
you then want to move on and you want to
leave CU there's going to be a time I
assume that you're going to want to
leave this behind I don't know if you
want to start a family if you want to
get married all of those things and you
go that's something you can never truly
leave behind is it uh absolutely
although I suspect that when most people
are evaluating this they're like not
aware of how different different
cultures can be like I think the thing
that you're describing would be true for
a pretty large majority of American
culture and probably in general Western
and ESP especially nonwestern
culture we're going to keep going yeah
can't imagine it would go downn well in
Saudi Arabia no although I'm sure
there's plenty of consumers from sa
Arabia but anyway carry on yeah but this
was this has never legitimately never
been a problem in my life because I'm
polyamorous and there's just like a
whole subculture thriving subculture of
people who are pretty sexually open and
don't mind it like in my friend groups
in like especially in the bay when I
live there so people don't give a
um like I'll go up and I'll like hey
worker on dates and the guy will be like
oh yeah my my ex-girlfriend was a sex
worker too she that was she really liked
it like it's a very common conversation
it's just not a thing that registers as
an issue really like you know I've
always thought I'm very liberal maybe
I'm just old and conservative because I
can't get my look I I can't get my head
around polyamory please explain it to me
like what are the benefits like to me it
just looks like needless admin
complications
frustrations is is it
just explain it to me please I I don't
understand uh well I mean you're you're
not wrong but the full story I think is
a little bit more nuanced yeah like I
did a study where I measured I think
30,000 people I asked them about their
relationship had them do a survey I
asked them how polyamorous how monog
starting you on a scale from like 1 to 7
um and then I asked them a whole bunch
of questions about the quality of their
relationship how much sex how long have
you been in this relationship and uh
people who are fully monogamous and
fully polyamorous had roughly the same
relationship quality they've been in
relationships for the same amount of
time so it's not like people who are
poly breaking up more um and they were
like yeah it's still going strong um but
people in the middle had much worse
ratings um and the problem is if you're
going to be selecting from a poly
population most people who aren't
monogamous are only slightly not
monogamous they're like a little bit
poly the majority of all people who are
not monogamous are in the middle um so
if you're just selecting randomly for
the N non monogamous population it's
going to look pretty bad what is
slightly mean um usually a married
couple opens their relationship uh but
they still they date together or married
couple opens their relationship but like
the person isn't having a full-time
relationship it's just sex that's an
example so I the question I guess I want
to ask is how do you divorce sex from
feelings or are these people who by
their nature or biologically able to do
that very easily yeah I guess to some
degree it's anate and genetic a lot of
probably people I know myself included
like don't really process jealousy the
same way like I remember before I had
heard of Paul am I was trying to dat
this guy when I was a teenager and he
went he was like I caught him sexting
with another girl and I was like G don't
do that like but I remember not really I
was like I couldn't summon the genuine
anger because I'm like what does this
have to do with me like he still wants
to have sex with me he still loves me
like I don't understand why this is
hurting me in any way and then as soon
as I heard what poam I was like oh yeah
so my guess is if you're thinking of
this closer to like almost to sexual
orientation I think that this I'm not
necessarily accurate but I think this
explains a lot closer to what's going on
like people are just processing
relationships differently and if you
have a whole bunch of those people in a
culture it goes pretty well but the
problem is you have to be quite
dedicated for it to seem to go well at
least in my data um I think a lot of
people are doing the partial thing as uh
way to sort of solve problems that exist
in previous relationships like if you
have monogamous PE people going oh we're
going to try you know opening it up
because like we're having these issues
I'm like you're opening it up to solve
issues it's not going to solve your
relationship like now you're just
with a terrible relationship yeah and
it's also as well I think you know
there's an element of fashion to it
where kind of no one wants to be like a
straight white dude anymore like
everybody like wants to be you know
something fluid or you poly is something
else but I just don't think many people
are compatible with it I think most
people would really struggle to see
their girlfriend go off and get you know
have sex with another dude I I think to
some degree you're right but there is a
thing where so one most people kind of
aren't monogamous anyway you want your
you don't want your partner to go
other people but you want to right uh
like the cheating rates and long-term
relationships are really high like if
you measure cheating rates by the amount
of time you've been in the relationship
and not by age which is what most
cheating rates do it's it seems to be
much higher like 40 45% yeah um it's
really depressing so most people buy
action in a world where we horribly
punish cheating are still cheating at
really high rates which makes me think
that we're not in ently monogamous in
the way that we would like aspire to be
this doesn't mean you shouldn't do it uh
well monogamy people would argue I mean
Lou Perry who you've done a debate with
who's who who's a friend of ours uh she
would argue monogamy is an adaptation
for stabilizing society that works very
well to do that uh I think this is
probably true at some points in history
do you don't think it's true now uh my
guess is that it is not sustainably true
now um or rather that like there are a
lot of things which are good if you only
have the capacity to process like simple
Nuance like uh it's probably uh if you
have let's see I'm trying to think
example um if you have uh somebody who
like abused their wife we it's probably
good as a social construct to just like
punish that person but if we have the
capacity as a society to make Nuance
between did you do it like because you
had a brain tumor um and we remove the
brain tumor you no longer feel violent
urges uh then I would say it would be
good to make this Nuance distinction and
so like I think that a lot of these
rules are sort of good for more
simplistic versions of society where
just cultural we don't have the ability
at scale to determine Nuance but I feel
like we're kind of hitting the point in
culture where we are able to and I'm
like the reality is if we are going to
look at the Nuance like monogamy is like
stable in some ways but there's lots of
versions of non- monogamy that have been
stable throughout history and a lot of
people are deeply unhappy in it and is
there a way that we can figure out to
move forward where we not crushing
people's Souls like if you look at
satisfaction rates happiness rates and
really long-term monogamous
relationships they're really low and to
be fair they're not great in polyamory
either but I'm saying like whatever
we're doing like whatever conception
we're having about relationships like I
I believe that we can figure out a way
to move forward and to like figure out
how to raise happiness and it's probably
not going to look like the thing it used
to look like no that and it's an
interesting point I suppose the one
thing is that what you're talking about
is essentially you're saying there is
room for subcultures to exist with in
society where people can go and live in
the way that's suitable for them the bit
that that leaves out is the raising of
children because you may be Polly and
you will be with I suppose several
people over the course of your lifetime
if you were to have kids you don't know
if you've got a genetically poly
predisposed kid and they're being raised
in that culture just kind of like you
were raised as a in in a Christian
conservative culture and you had to go
and find a different one right um so it
complicates the raising of children
because Norms that exist they exclude
minority people but they also give the
majority a structure for how to live
life that with without which people will
be lost quite a lot of the time would
that be fair to say uh I think that this
is true but like you could argue should
we not have gay people raising kids and
some people do argue this but they are a
minority raising children and we
generally seem to be okay with this um
and secondarily like my guess is that
probably more people are interested in
some degree of the poly Spectrum than we
think like we have such like can you
remember the last uh romantic movie you
saw that was
polyamorous no yeah they don't exist we
just don't have monog give it a couple
of years I reckon we're going to see one
soon I would hope so the thing is like
we have like a lot of like gay Cinema
but we have nothing for polyamory at all
and we have like a whole culture that's
structured to show monogamous people
like how to live this is these are the
subtle social rules for how to
communicate with each other in a
monogamous setting which I think is
great like it really helps it run a lot
smoother and if you and my guess is if
we had some instructions like some
cultural media instructions for like how
does poly relationships work how do you
handle jealousy uh because we just don't
know this and I think it would make it
go a lot smoother and I think probably a
lot more people would feel comfortable
trying a poly lifestyle in a way that
actually ends up being successful um but
that is slightly besides your point uh
personally so I think it is true it does
seem that poly people raise a lot fewer
children in my data they have kids at
around half the rate of people who
reported being monogamous even
controlling for age and relationship
length um which is not great but I know
a lot of people poly people who do raise
kids successfully
so we're going to be at the Battle of
ideas on the 28th and the 29th of
October in London the Battle of ideas is
a festival of free speech that happens
in London every year where you will see
some of your favorite guests from
trigonometry coming to London to take
part in debates not only that both
Francis and I will be
there I'll be taking part in the spike
podcast and also in a discussion about
online censorship and I'll be there
talking about mizy From Misery to online
civility I think that's the name of it
basically we're going to be talking
about mzy and what a horrible little so
so he is yeah come along uh not just for
that but also because there'll be lots
of cool people there make sure to say
hello to us if you see us grab your
tickets today by going to the Battle of
ideas website and if you want a 20%
discount it's available to all our
supporters on locals so if you're not
already there head on over subscribe get
your 20%
off and AA do you think that this rise
of Polly and all and you know these
other kind of Lifestyles should we call
them or ways of living do you think it's
because we're viewing sex more and more
as a as a form of recreation rather than
in the biblical sense where it was
procreation I guess which I mean comes
from probably birth control right like
if you're not we no longer have like a
God's Eternal punishment for having
sex that's a very very particular way of
describing children
yeah you you met my son earlier I don't
consider him God's punishment for sex I
have to say I think I'm thinking of like
horror houses back in the day without
birth control where all these children
are running around you don't have the
like societal capacity to care for them
yeah with this is what I mean about
children are lovely I would like to have
kids um but in this in this sense yeah
uh but it's divorced because of birth
control yeah the that that's an
interesting point uh what I was going to
ask you about coming back to sex work is
one of the things I I I read or watched
you say which I find very interesting
was um camming and only fans you said
was quite unhealthy in terms of your
your me your
well-being but being an escort was much
better yeah very much I think that is
incredibly coun inuitive to a lot of
people because I suppose because of the
attachments they have to what sex means
they I suppose they would see it as
unwanted sex and therefore if you can at
least not have it with another person
then it's good but you clearly have a
completely different experience of it
well we have Norms where people are
expected to have unwanted sex all the
time in long-term monogamous marriages
and like I wouldn't argue that's
necessarily bad like maybe to some
degree there's a duty where as a wife
you should keep your husband been
satisfied cuz if he can only get sex
from one place and typically it's the
man wanting sex from the women although
it's not always so I don't know like the
concept of like having to have sex that
you're just like not that into like sure
people do this people have been doing
this for all of human history man it's
like but and by people you mean women
mostly mostly yeah but I was also really
surprised to find this with the sex work
thing too like uh it was after I did
escorting and I went back to only fans
and I was like it just feels
dehumanizing like in both ways I feel
like I'm dehumanizing my C customers and
my customers are dehumanizing me when
I'm online but in person like to to the
degree that I can safely and comfortably
feel love for my client I allow myself
to do so I really like feeling like a
part of me really cares about them in
that moment and that's the thing that I
just can't experience with only fans
because it's somebody on the other side
of a text box and you're communicating
often
asynchronously um but like in person you
get to like have that one-on-one thing
like my entire being right now is like
having a genuine connection with another
individual and then that you can like
touch Souls a little bit and I love
every like that this happened for every
client that I've had in the past that
just not not so much of the only fan
it's interesting I have a couple of
questions about that but the first one
is I think what you're describing oddly
enough and I didn't expect this to come
up in a in a conversation with a sex
worker is actually the the human
Paradigm in the 21st century which is
we're all connecting in ways that are
fake through avatars and actually we all
crave a real human Connection in meat
space yeah and I found it made me feel
better too yeah really so the question
that I was going to ask though is and
this is com coming from a Normy place so
I hope it doesn't sound judgmental or
whatever but I think a lot of people
will want to know this is like you can't
be attracted to every guy that wants to
pay you money to have sex with you right
that's not possible I'm guessing right
yeah well I'm not attracted to most men
right yeah thank you for making that
c u but you know what I mean though it's
like you talk about having that
connection and almost feeling a love for
somebody that you're not even attracted
to mhm how does that happen I can't tell
how much I'm a normal woman or a weird
woman when it comes to sexual response
um
but I just like my vagina just responds
with lubrication when there's a new
penis it doesn't matter if I'm attracted
to them or not so it worked fine but
like to me I'm not processing like is
this guy hot like to me there's just
like dude it's like a generic like dude
form uh and I just like have sex it's
like giving them a massage I don't know
it's like do I have to be attracted to
someone to give them a massage it's like
giving them a
massage or like yeah or doing therapy
it's like I don't have to find you hot
to do therapy on no I get it but but sex
is different surely I'm yeah this is I
can't tell if I'm similar to most women
or not no you're not similar to most
women I can tell you that but a lot of
other sex I've talked to it's like I
don't know they sex this is where we're
getting to is like I think there's
probably a a minority of women who are
able to process sex in a very different
way to the to to other women don't have
to call it normal you could just call it
the majority or whatever where sex is a
tool for creating long-term attachment
to create security for the for the
potential creation of life that then is
protected and fed Etc right mhm um
but yeah it's it's an sorry no I was
just gonna
say do
so I mean okay right I guess the
question I want to ask is isn't sex more
than that though yeah isn't sex about
connection
ultimately isn't it about you know
trying to create a bond and therefore I
mean that's what I feel sex is but if
that is the case then don't
you catch feelings as the kids would say
from your clients not really I not like
it takes a lot more than sex for me to
catch feelings like I have to like the
person like we have to have a connection
in ways that aren't just about sex uh
sex can help but um there's an example
where so I used to throw naked parties
and people before they would come would
be like oh God this is going to be
really weird what if I get a boner what
if I'm staring at boobs the whole time
it was really nerve-wracking then they
would come and then often report I'm
actually shocked by how quickly my brain
like recontextualizes nudity I'm here
and there's just a bunch of bodies and
it's like somehow not sexual um I didn't
expect that this could happen because
we've never been exposed to nudity in
like wide nonsexual context before and I
think that there's something like this
going on with sex like if you've only
ever experienced sex in context where
the narrative is that this is like a
highly important connective thing then
that's what you're going to expect but
like weirdly if you just kind of start
experiencing sex in other context it
works there too like exposure to the
naked parties didn't make nudity less
sexy in other contexts as I assume
doctors still can get aroused
their wives even if they look at a bunch
of vaginas but it's just expands the
ways that sex can be meaningful to you
instead of keeping it narrow okay so the
other question
is the biggest threat to women is
men and have you ever worked worried
that you were putting yourself as a
woman in a vulnerable position by doing
this type of work definitely uh it's
like oddly like the internet stuff has
turned out to be a little bit more
threatening um there's a guy showed at
my house and tried to murder me last
year which was pretty scary um I can
imagine yeah that's awful so and was it
I mean obviously we don't want to go too
much into detail because we don't want
to give this person publicity but was it
former client former no I did complete
Rando never seen him before he had never
tried to contact me the guy just showed
up at my house just as an FBI officer
and told me to get in the car so I was
under arrest which I believe him CU he
don't expect but it turned out he had
brought like a garot and hunting knife
and stuff wow and luckily I did not get
in the car but you yeah and so and but
and people track this person and
obviously the police track this person
yeah and they have no idea how he came
to discover who you are why he believed
these things or just random internet but
they found um they they told me that
they found the information of other sex
workers in his house okay so the this is
my current theory is that he was just
targeting sex workers basically because
when I was doing research you sound like
you you do very well out of this very
very well I was reading like $100,000 a
month only fans $3,000 an hour for like
a a session or whatever it may be called
um you're coming across very comfortable
in this yeah I know mate I
know yeah I know um but I I guess do do
you not feel like you put yourself in
danger every time that you do this
and I guess is that not a concern a
worry that you especially if you don't
need the money
anymore yeah but I would rather like die
being who I am than live trying to hide
like if I could go over and be like you
oh you're no longer at risk from murder
but you like are not very open about who
you are on the internet are you're
trying to hide like I would rather I'd
rather take the scary Road and do you
still do
escorting so I I suppose the question is
given that you as Francis says you do
very well out of only
fans you must enjoy escorting y clearly
which I was surprised to find yeah yeah
I think that's really the core of where
I think a nor normal I don't use it in
any judgmental sense just a a a
mainstream whatever the I hate
this world where you can't just say what
you mean yeah I think the disconnect
between a normal person and what you're
saying is contained in that thing which
is you you enjoy that you enjoy that
work uh yeah I I turns out that I like
sex with new people it's just really
nice um and it's difficult to do for me
in that like I feel kind of awkward and
confused about how to initiate sex with
another person um but if they're paying
for it then it's clear oh you show up
and it's the whole thing is laid out for
you so you kind of you would be doing
this anyway but you're just getting paid
for it is that what you're saying uh to
some degree if I were doing this for
free which I do well I have a survey
where people can apply to have sex with
me and then if they're like highly
sexually compatible then I contact
you've really taken the admin side of
this to the next level haven't you I
don't think you like sex I think you
like admin I think like Frenchy yeah I
think what gets you off is Excel let's
be honest yeah yeah so so you have the
survey and you have sex with some of the
people who are highly compatible with
you what does highly compatible mean
they into the same weird Kinks that I'm
into okay and this was going to be my
other question which is I imagine the
people who pay to have sex with a sex
worker they have an idea a of how they
want that to go yeah generally it's
quite
vanilla really yes super vanilla they
just they pay money to have sex in the
missionary position basically uh I mean
so I'm not saying that they don't have
fetishes I'm saying that in general the
way that escorting is structured is that
you're not supposed to discuss uh what
you're into beforehand because for legal
risk reasons there's a lot of things
about the fact that escorting is illegal
that makes it like dangerous and hard um
like for example I did get assaulted
once when I was escorting couldn't go to
the police um but that aside uh yeah so
you're not allowed to basically talk
about sex acts in advance and so it's
quite hard for people to locate and
negotiate people who are open to various
specific things so I have met a lot of
people um who maybe have preferences for
fetishes but they tend to be kind of
mild and they tend to be shy about
asking for them AA we've had a feminist
on the show called Julie bindle who is a
fantastic writer and thinker we both
love Julie and both big fans she has
campaigned for a long time to make
prostitution illegal and to criminalize
the men who seek out
prostitutes what's the other side why
should prostitution and escorting why
should it be legal yeah if you talk to
any active escort uh almost all of them
will say that they would uh disagree
with making illegal yeah so like usually
when people Advocate that I'm like
sounds like you have either not talked
to escorts or you have talked to like
small percentage that left it and had a
bad time um but there's a whole bunch
that are this is your life's work um and
if you talk to us you would find out
that man I would like to uh see men and
then not get punished for it and I would
like to see men and not have them get
punished for it um the Nordic model is
also pretty bad um like the incentive
structure is like
uh one of the ways that you get treated
better as an escort is if you're able to
like charge more and basically have more
bargaining power yeah um if you increase
Supply and reduced demand um this makes
it so that the supply side has less
bargaining power um which means that
you're more likely to take uh safety
risks in order to like and charge less
money um and in my data charging less
money is correlated with higher rates of
um being offended against or like having
bad things happen to you like being
assaulted um so if you are uh making it
illegal for the men but not the women
you're going to have a higher supply of
women and fewer men um which just
basically makes the power imbalance
pretty bad and makes it way more prone
to having bad things happen uh but yeah
I basically all I'm not asking for much
I would just like to go to the police
when someone assaults me and not have
them arrest me because I accepted money
for something that a lot of other people
do for free right
and I I do find it upsetting Aya I'm
going to be honest with you that you
talk about being assaulted in such a
casual manner you know it's I that's
just a natural human response from me
I'm just being honest with you I it's
it's really not great I agree it's it's
um unpleasant I would rather have been
assaulted than worked at the factory to
be clear like the but but also like the
fact that I was assaulted could have
been prevented if it were not illegal if
if prosecution was criminalized the
thing that got me into that place yeah
because what happened is like if you can
vet men properly beforehand if you're
able to have like more resources poured
into excellent black lists for women to
share which right now that you have to
operate in the shadows because this is
of aiding prostitution so like if you if
you decriminalize prostitution and then
women will have the tools to make
themselves safer and it will
dramatically decrease the risk of
assault and is there any particular
country that you know gets it right as
far as you're concerned or does bet is
is better to the model that you would
like to see I don't know I haven't
talked to enough sex workers from those
countries yeah which is the way that I
would determine I would go to those sex
workers and be like how safe do you feel
how much do you feel like you're getting
like your money taken away from you by
like
Co of brothel for example okay so I
don't know do you have a website or do
you plan to have a website because if
you do then easy DNS is a company for
you easy DNS is the perfect domain name
registar provider and webhost for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients whether it be cancel
culture deplatform attacks or
overzealous government agencies he knows
about that so we'll you in a second easy
DNS have Rock Solid Network
infrastructure and fantastic customer
support they're in your corner no matter
what the world throws at you unless it's
your ex-girlfriend in which case you're
on your own you know about that move
your domains and websites over to easy
DNS right now all you've got to do is go
to easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for the new
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship we've talked about escorting
we've talked about only fans I mean we
kind of haven't talked about the porn
the porn industry which is the making
the movies Etc did that side of it ever
appeal to you and if not why not it
didn't because you make a lot less money
okay for a lot less control I think like
the Advent of like to some degree
camming but especially only fans has
just ripped the power away from from the
like the centralized Industries which I
think is kind of good it's like the New
Media of porn right it's like YouTube
taking
over the TV that that that makes a lot
of sense um I suppose you know I'm just
curious asking all these questions from
an Nory perspective because I think a
lot of people watching will have them um
the thing that I think a lot of people
would say is
that um sex is I mean sacred makes me
sound like a religious n but that's how
a lot lot of people will feel about it
whether they're religious or not uh they
a lot of people feel that sex has a
meaning beyond the physical act and
Louise Perry who as I say you've debated
before she gives us example of if we
just treated sex like any other service
there would be absolutely no reason why
it would be offensive for your boss
whose secretary you are to say well if
you give me a I'll give you a
raise right because it's just like
giving a massage like you said like why
why wouldn't do you see what I'm saying
do we consider offensive to be like if
you give me a massage I'll give you a
raise uh only because there's a sexual
Dimension to it if if I said to my
secretary if you make my coffee on time
every week and it's exactly the way that
I want it I'll give you a raise I the
job description like if you're like if
you wash my car I'll give you a raise
like that starts to feel a little bit
weirder and exploitative because it's
outside the job description like I don't
think we okay if I have a PA and I say
to her him or her in in our case it's
him can you go and take my car to the
car
wash You could argue that's within this
job description let's pick something
that is clearly not within the job
description like can you watch my kids
like in the same way fine watch my kids
right that would feel a little weird as
weird as having giving someone a
uh well I think it's just like the the
sense of exploitation that we have like
oh I have power over you and I will
dangle money if you do something like
personal for me okay but what I'm saying
is something else which is if I was to
say to my
PA watch my kids for an hour and you get
a raise I don't think that in society
and under the law and in all sorts of
other important ways that would be
treated anything like me offering my
secretary raise for a blowj job yeah I
agree so I think there's two things
going on that I think this analogy is
conflating and one is like like
exploitation of power um and but the
other is like it is clear that like a
lot of people have a lot of loaded
feelings around if you were
like hey I have a job description in
which I want you to assist me and also
part of the job is give me and
somebody signed up for that people might
be horrified but I think that we should
allow this as a society like two
consenting adults deciding that they are
want to voluntarily enter this let's WR
the job
description let's get the job adver out
right now I just realized I rub my hands
that looks Dreadful that looks Dreadful
and we probably need to cut it this has
not been my fin going in this is going
in the one thing that we're not
acknowledging here Aya and I think we
need to is there's a fly on your head
there's a fly on head this looks like an
episode filmed in Africa I have to say
exactly I don't know what's happened
with the flies anyway anyway so the
question that I want to ask is this why
I am literally surrounded by flies I've
got one and I've killed one we can cut
that you're you're Barack Obama do you
remember when he killed the fly really
yeah everyone thought he was a real man
as a result there you go they did he
killed killed the fly and was like get
that show it on camera yeah show that
I'm a man in charge of my own destiny I
can kill an insect obviously all the
Buddhists have switched off now but what
we're not acknowledging here Aya is the
power
Dynamic well she did yes she did
acknowledge it but but but I don't think
that we we really delved into it do you
see what I mean like there is a very
very real power Dynamic and we've seen
it again and again and we use the
example of Pas but there's other
Industries particularly the performing
Arts Industries for instance where this
has been in existence for decades if not
centuries and it's deeply
exploitative uh yeah I generally don't
like I find the word exploitative to be
like a little bit confused and loaded
but I agree that like sex is a very
loaded thing that a lot of men want and
a lot of women are like G don't have it
with me um and so if you introduce this
thing with like really intense
incentives into any it's going to like
warp things around it people are going
to be like oh maybe if I have sex with
my boss he'll give me a raise or you
know the boss will be like oh maybe
she'll have sex with me to get a raise I
agree that this is like a thing that
warps incentives your question okay
listen I've got a way of adding to the
example we were working with earlier
that might be helpful let's say I go to
my secretary and I say to her your job
description currently is to make coffee
to run my diary to book appointments
blah blah blah blah blah however you
currently get paid let's say $50,000 uh
$50,000 a year let's say right I'm going
to double your salary if we modify your
job description to include the following
sex act you think that's a perfectly
reasonable thing of of an employer to
offer an employee uh I I think it should
be allowed
yeah like because she can say no right
she can but I imagine most people's
reaction to that sort of proposal would
be one of intense Horror
oh I don't have that horror reaction I
can tell yeah yeah that that's really
interesting that that you don't have
that reaction because also as well the
woman tends to sexual woman is far more
Frau than sex or a man you take you can
lose a lot more you have more risk of
cre of
uh C catching an STD you know there's a
potential for pregnancy etc etc etc
there's a reputational damage as well
mhm
so you would say take away the
reputational damage I'm guessing right I
I would say what take for most people
there is reputational damage yes I agree
because you know if somebody does that
and you know it's you know and you your
argument is look these are two
consenting adults and they come to this
agreement who are we to make a comment
well we all know that society and by
Society I mean women don't really see it
like that because there will be a lot of
women who
will men a lot of men as well who will
just say look this is disgusting and a
hubor this person is a is a you know and
they will say all these awful things uh
yeah that's true there's a lot of it's
very intense stigma against sex work but
I think it's interesting so for example
seeking Arrangement is this you are you
familiar with this website it's a
website where it's not escorting and
it's not quite dating it's like you can
be a sugar daddy and like so typically
for wealthier men to find poor women and
then you take them out to dinner and you
buy them gifts in exchange for an
arrangement typically involving sex um
and this is not prostitution because
it's like dating this happens all the
time normal that doesn't wash for me but
like normal dating a lot of normal
dating culture abides by these rules
unspoken like girls want a rich man rich
rich man fantasies are like everywhere
the 50 Shades of Gray he's a billionaire
like Twilight he's a super like wealthy
old person or something um but I'm
saying that like in general the ancient
exchange is like a man provides
Financial stability for a woman and she
provides him a child or by proxy sex
yeah um and I'm saying to some extent
this is always taking place and the more
you obfuscate it the more you're saying
oh I'm not exchanging sex for money I'm
exchanging money for some other things
um like financial support it's very tra
I'm saying very Trad things this is not
crazy um then people are much more
willing to abide by it and what's
interesting is that the seeking
arrangement prices are much lower than
the escort prices like if you're a
seeking Arrangement girl you can charge
maybe 50% if if you were being an escort
um and this I think we can see as the
premium on
explicitness so if you're a girl doing
this thing normally but you say
explicitly I'm going to just have sex
you get to charge a lot more because
fewer women are willing to do that um so
I think like the question is not um are
women willing to exchange sex for Value
but rather the horror is at explicitly
saying that they're doing that yeah yes
yes yeah that is a very Trad thing to
say in many ways and many a comedian has
has done a bit on this obviously uh but
moving on I'm curious you also do a lot
of research with the stuff that you do
uh and I was curious if you had any
insight I mean 50 Shades of Gray was
like by far in a way the best book uh
the best selling but not the best I'm
not personally endorsing it good Freud
and slip there we've covered ourselves
in glory on this we look even worse than
the theovon interview yeah anyway
um what I was going to say is it was
immensely popular and it feels to me
like within that there's some kind of
social taboo about naming whatever that
power Dynamic tends to be between men
and women what is your insight into why
that book was and movie was so popular
and what sort of is behind all of that I
mean it's just porn for women like this
is no but isn't the narrative is though
that uh evil pornography has created the
demand in men for rough sex which is
horrific to women
and this is kind of like male
exploitation you laughed when I said
that why did you laugh it's it's just
like there's a lot of things I can agree
debates about oh is SE sex work you know
bad or good for Society at large I'm
like this like a reasonable thing to
inquire but like when it comes to the
porn thing it's just one of the things
that I find to be so lacking any
evidence
uh the evidence is all to the opposite
and there's quite a bit of it like my
research and a lot of established
researches said that women have way more
interest in like violent rough power
dynamics am menu significant like it's
just clear it's like one of the most
established things which is why I'm like
I don't understand why this narrative is
so popular so s to interrupt I really
want to hear the rest of it but just to
spell it out
and what you're saying is the evidence
is in your opinion that uh women are
more interested in rough sex y than men
very much I I did one survey um it was
both of my own audience and also paid
random sample um of people asking to
predict what do you think the other
person would like in bed and then for
men to predict to women what do you
think the women would like in bed and I
listed a whole bunch of things and then
I asked women um assuming that the guy
is well intentioned like he actually
thinks you're going to like it assuming
he's safe whatever um what things would
you respond well to if he tried them in
bed um and so we get to see like a list
of like what guys think ladies like and
what girls say they actually want um and
but then I I checked it by how much porn
do you want and the more porn a man
watched the more accurate he was at
guessing what women wanted in bed and
the big difference is the biggest
difference was choking between what
women reported they wanted to happen and
what men thought that women would be
okay with this is just like one small
study there's like a whole bunch more
and The evolutionary rationale for this
I'm guessing would be that a lot of
women have DNA
that I mean
a lot of women historically were in
situations where it was advantageous to
be turned on by somebody who was strong
and powerful and quite often actually a
rapist right yeah like I mean if you
look at like chimps for example their
whole sexual world is full of violence
and like aggression and mateu guarding
and like the males making sure the
females aren't don't go off alone with
another man and like threatening them uh
so it seems like pretty possible that we
have something like this in our own
history um but there's other questions
like it's possible that it's a falling
testosterone thing because there's some
evidence to suggest that testosterone is
correlated with sexual dominance and if
everybody's um testosterone is dropping
then we would see women more submissive
and Men less interested in dominance is
a possibility wow there's also a thing
where as a female like maybe in history
if you reproduce with like a very
aggressive man your sons are going to be
more likely to reproduce like you're
going to give birth to like like more
like I say rapy but like more like you
know dominant more like kind of
aggressive kind of males which are going
to have greater reproductive success
yeah the history is not always
flattering but so you're doing your sex
research which is very interesting so I
I mean the billion dollar question is
what is it that women want from men on
the whole what is it that they want from
a partner what is it that they want on
average from a sexual partner it depends
a lot it depends a lot on the woman like
a lot of women are submissive but this
is like roughly 60% and it depends on
how you define submissive there's like
different way but roughly 60% so that
that's like barely more than half so we
have a whole 40% that aren't interested
in that at all um so like to say like
one generalization is going to be quite
hard but I think generally competence is
pretty valued um competence and an
attentiveness and power like if you can
establish yourself as a sexually
desirable mate like a lot of other women
want you um but that basically if you
could just be a romance novel
protagonist
honestly uh yeah a lot of other ladies
want you um and but you are kind of
non-reactive to women um what does that
mean non-reactive uh sort of like you in
the same way that like being an
attractive woman is being very reactive
to the man like he wants to to know that
he has like the ability to like change
your mental state in like positive or
negative ways make you yeah like you
tease you and you like have a strong
response um and this indicates like
vulnerability and I don't know like
peness but like what women want is
basically the reverse you want like a
who is not like super reactive to you he
wants to be like steady and strong and
sort of stoic in a way would be very
common really and normally women always
say sense of humor is that a thing or is
that just a myth I no that's a thing
really demonstrating that competence and
intelligence yeah but the thing I would
suggest with humor is humor frequently
is a coping mechanism It's A coping
mechanism and it's normally you look at
every standup comedian that I've ever
met they're all ADHD out of their brain
including me so like how does that work
you know are are you do you use those A
coping mechanism yeah absolutely I see
yeah I wonder if there's a difference
between Comedians and normal people
though who are just funny yeah there is
yeah comedians are mental that's
the difference dude I know one of the
like most emotionally traumatized
clients I ever had was a
comedian I'm pausing for an extra time
wait waiting for you to say his name but
I didn't expect it to come
that yeah that's interesting okay so
that that would get a lot more clicks
right yeah we're going to we're going to
do a little poll to see who we think it
is yeah um um but so so so let's look at
it on in terms of a kind of almost like
a league table as it were and scient
unscientific as that term is so what is
the thing that women desire the most on
average is it the stoicness is it depend
dependability is it the competence is it
this is like asking like what is the
most Central feature to being a woman
yeah it's like some things but like uh
it's a really fraught topic yeah uh I
think like generally power is pretty
close and they can manifest in a lot of
different ways but yeah yeah that makes
a lot of sense and for for very good
evolutional reasons a in terms of your
research what I I'd love to know is what
do you think are some of the most
misunderstood and also just like we
don't talk about the truth about sex
Dynamics men and women like what are the
things that people pretend that are true
that are not true pretend aren't true
that are true do you just see what I'm
I'm getting in oh uh probably the origin
of fetishes oh tell us about that well
so well fetishes in general like we
don't have good research at all about
how sexuality works I mean we know a
couple clues here and there like maybe
hormones cause being gay or something
but beyond that we just don't have a
clue and the contrast of how much we
know versus the amount of very intense
cultural uh supposed knowledge like
you'll have people very confidently
making claims about uh like oh well you
know you're into like sexual like rape
play because you're abused as a child
which technically is correct but you
don't know that um there's just a a lot
of like oh you know you're into foot
fetishes because you're exposed to feet
as a kid um one we all exactly exposed
to Fe I I I mean I saw quite a lot of
feet I don't have a
but also as well what is a fetish
because in this incredibly polarized
time you know if a guy for instance
likes and is sex more sexually attracted
to I don't know Asian women that is seen
as a fetish or is that a sexual
preference yeah I don't think like these
words are like we can use words to refer
to things but there's no hard line and I
think in general like when people are
like researching fetishes and paraphilia
I don't think those terminologies are
very useful all we have is is just
sexual interests and some are more
common than others we have a spectrum
and we have a spectrum of like how taboo
are is your sexual interest and we can
like use a word to refer to like well
kind of the fetishist at this far end
are maybe more fetishy or something I
saw a great meme about that which is
like it's three normal boxes like guys
who like boobs guy who likes butts guy
who like something else and then feet
and there's like this guy seen
brilliant so how how how do fetishes
develop you you were saying earlier we
don't know uh don't know
my this is one of the things I'm trying
to find in my research and it's like a
weird amount of stuff doesn't correlate
that you would think do correlate like
for example being spanked in childhood
does correlate with interest in spanking
in adulthood but only barely like it
wouldn't really you wouldn't be able to
predict it very much um and this is like
really counter to a lot of narratives
about how like spanking fetishes develop
for example it's it's really weird yeah
although there one of the strange I need
to look at the I have a lot of data that
I'm like slowly working through so I've
kind of done some glancing so let's take
it with a grain of salt but it seems
that um there's unusual relationship in
childhood and fetishes for Trans men
specifically but not trans women or uh
straight or CIS people like as in things
in childhood correlate a lot more with
fetishes in adulthood but only for that
category that's really interesting and
why is it that a foot fetish is a pretty
mainstream thing get it it has such a
strong like if I knew someone had a foot
fetish I'll be honest with you I'd be
I'd think there a little bit weird do
you know what I mean yeah you know foot
finishes are actually relatively
uncommon given how aware we are of them
yeah yeah it's but it's they've got
great P yeah it's like you know there's
a and we don't know this is a rumor you
know Tarantino has a foot fetish and
then you look at every single one of his
movies and and then there is like you
know there's the toes sucking or
whatever it may be in in his movies and
you
go I I kind of and maybe this is me
being Prim and proper like there's a
slight judgmental a to it do you know
what I mean do you feel the same about
like gay people for example which oh no
but I just think foot fetishes are what
about like fuzzy handcuffs sorry fuzzy
handcuffs like somebody's like I really
want to be in fuzzy handcuffs no okay I
just like trying to find like where the
line is what about somebody wants to pee
on on you that's weird okay
that's too that's weird yeah what El
somebody who's really into like braids
they really braid if a girl put their
hair and braids they're just like that's
really
hot that is that a sex fetish that's
just a hairy anything is a fetish well
look I kind of get like if you're having
sex and you pull the braids do you know
what I
mean like just you can pull look this is
this conversation is going the wrong way
fast cuz I was about to say you can pull
hair too anyway no braids is not weird
peeing weird feet weird weird Okay feet
feet weird it's just weird and I you ask
me and like but you got right let's look
at this logically right do you like
boobs yes do you like bums yes so what's
the difference there is nothing there is
no difference between like bums and feet
but well it's just a part of the human
body you you you're attracted to a part
of the human body some people are
attracted to that part of the human body
shows the toenail yeah doesn't mean
toenail fetishes are normal it's
weird by by weird you mean abnormal yeah
like most FES are pretty abnormal yeah
and it's just like I don't think I'd
trust someone if they had a foot face no
I I wouldn't you should be able to
employ L friends who have a foot fetish
say again you probably know many people
many of your friends probably have a
foot fetish but have not told you well
if you are you're no longer our friends
yeah
unsubscribe definitely imagine we come
back to the channel I
har turns out we just attracted a legion
of foot
fetishes well it's been a lot of fun uh
thank thank you for letting us sort of
prod and find stuff out it's been really
really cool to chat with you I feel like
my virginity has grown back at times so
thank you for that yeah no but it's been
really fun um the question we last
question we always ask is uh what's
before we go to our locals where we ask
you questions from our audience and if
there's any foot fetish people you're
getting
deleted unless you're a top level Patron
in which case welcome yeah exactly will
you be posting photos of your feed for
your patrons we should do that shouldn't
we do you know you know what we could
make way more money than we do now just
selling pictures of our feet I we're not
women so it wouldn't happen but I mean
imagine that imagine if like Rogan
contacted us like next year like hey
Lads you want to come back on the Pod
turns out mate we're making way more
money sending pictures of feet feometry
yeah anyway AA before we go to locals
where we'll ask you questions from our
audience uh the last question we always
finish with is an opportunity for you to
basically say whatever you think which
is what's the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
uh I'm trying to think of what we
already covered maybe like a
modification on some things I've said uh
uh for my perspective having been in sex
work for 10 years in the last I would
say two to four years there's been um a
change on the internet like a prudish
chilling effect uh there's been a
backlash basically against sexuality
that's starting to shut down what is
allowed to be posted where um that I
find to be quite tragic as a lover of
sexuality and this is I haven't seen
people talking about this like the the
ne tell us more then because what are
you talking about specifically I just
like the things that are allowed on the
internet just aren't anymore like on
only fans you can't do bondage material
um you used to be able to like they've
taken down a whole bunch of fetish
options from websites um a whole bunch
of sex subreddits got banned from Reddit
like a couple years ago um anything
that's like abnormal the sex R reddits
by the way the niche ones got also
banned with like a lot of things
dedicated to trans discourse on both
sides so whatever sort of uh prudish
effect is coming is stealing like oh
anything that's like too edgy or too
inappropriate might make people feel
offended um these are just getting
whitewashed off the internet like Duck
Dogo for example used to be the go-to
porn engine it's supposed to be the
uncensored one you can't search porn on
there anymore it's non-p porn um so
basically like sexuality especially
Niche sexuality and especially like edgy
ones that most people like are a little
offended by
um are like slowly getting censored off
of everywhere and nobody cares because
it's porn like with like trans discourse
people fight about it and then we have a
whole culture War but nobody's willing
to stand up publicly for like the weird
Niche sex stuff and I find that really
tragic actually I was going to ask you
about trans but we'll ask you uh about
that in the local section so thanks so
much for coming on head on over to
locals where we continue the
conversation what do you make of the
whole trans
conversation
[Music]